the whole breathing technique that she's
doing with the
i've never actually heard that in my
career hi
i am dr ali rodriguez i am an ob gyn
today we're going to be looking at
pregnancy scenes in movies and in tv
and judging them for realism that's it
the doctor will be right in
thanks thank you you know i think they
did do a good job in this one in making
the baby bump look
real i think i mean it's believable i
think she looks pregnant to me
let's check again in two weeks
[Music]
how big the belly gets when we do fundal
height
that's the measurement um from the pubic
bone
all the way to the top of the uterus the
top of the uterus is called the fundus
which is why it's called bundle height
that is something that's typically not
done standing up
it would be very uncomfortable and very
difficult to do
because the more you know obviously
bigger you get in pregnancy
it's gonna be harder to get down to that
pubic bone
accurately from the squatting
position that she's doing instead of the
belly growing
like outward we'd expect it to grow
almost up
because the uterus and baby are growing
up but currently the babies breach
head is up here tush is down here and
the baby needs to be head down for a
natural delivery
i think the doctor does do a good job of
explaining what that means and
almost not to worry at this point
throughout pregnancies babies will turn
from breech to cephalic and they'll kind
of do flips and
twirl around in there and that's okay
typically by the point that a
you know a patient is 33 weeks that's
when we really want baby to kind of
start moving towards head down
because like she mentions at the end of
the clip you know the bigger baby gets
and the closer you are to full term
they start running out of room so if
they haven't flipped by then
it's unlikely for them to you know flip
on their own just because they just
don't have the space anymore
it looks very real she looks pregnant to
me and i think they did a good job
so yeah i'd say seven out of ten
certainly birth can be traumatic you
know a patient comes in
completely dilated or you know having
really bad contractions at home
that's when it can get a little
traumatic but usually
it's really not traumatic obviously it
makes it more entertaining and funny
um to have it be this way
[Applause]
i always tell all of my patients you
know pushing and going through labor
is a lot of work and you are going to be
pushing pretty
hard in order for it to be i guess
effective it's not necessarily how
hard you're pushing but are you using
the right muscles so
as funny as it sounds the same muscles
we use to go to the bathroom are the
same muscles we use
to push out a baby
usually when we see um clips in movies
you always have that blue sheet
kind of draped over the legs
and honestly that's rarely ever used
i don't think i've ever used it in any
of the deliveries the patient always has
a hospital gown on definitely
oh that's a pretty big baby um see the
average
size or weight of a newborn is anywhere
between
six to seven pounds and they're usually
about like 19 to 20 inches long
this baby to me appears to be much
bigger than that
i don't think they're actually using a
newborn for these scenes
they definitely show like this clean
baby and here
it looks like they've you know done a
little bit of makeup but typically
babies
are born with something called vernix
but
this vernix it's almost serves as a
protective um
covering over and fetuses skin when
they're in utero
it almost looks like a really white
thick lotion and i think that's what
they tried to kind of put the makeup on
the baby
as you can see there's white little
chunks think of it as like a baby lotion
so it's okay to kind of rubbing it into
their skin
but i am going to give it to them i
think they did a good job of trying to
put the makeup on the baby
i'd give it a 5 out of 10.
one of the first presenting symptoms of
early pregnancy can be nausea and
vomiting
a lot of my patients they'll cook a
whole meal
and then they sit down to eat it and
they just want to vomit you have that
surge of estrogen
progesterone um human um or i guess hcg
it was just a pregnancy hormone
increases and all of that
you know there's a heightened sense of
smell
in women who are pregnant
seeing this much blood is not concerning
seeing a vampire do the c-section with
his teeth is
very impressive and concerning but yeah
typically at childbirth is a process
that is very bloody
we obviously don't want them to lose too
much which is why we still monitor
vitals
and when you're closer to that 40 weeks
gestation
the uterus and the baby are getting
about 450 milliliters of blood
in a minute after delivery you still
have
all of that blood that's pumping to the
uterus
so if there's some sort of you know
issue
or something going on that's a lot of
blood that a patient's going to lose
in a matter of seconds simply cannot
handle this one this gets a one out of
ten
this is just too much over the top
and very unrealistic i just took the
pregnancy test
just tell me when a minute's up i just
put some pizza rolls in the microwave
oven
the minute that bad boy dings we're good
to go i think it'd be a good distraction
from it because you know it's sometimes
a moment that can be
very nerve-wracking and cause a lot of
anxiety so i think
distracting yourself with something is a
good idea
by the way next time buy a name brand
pregnancy test not that cheap generic
one
some of them are definitely advertised
to you know find out
at the earliest point in pregnancy and
that just simply means those ones may be
a little bit more
sensitive to the level of pregnancy
hormone most of these pregnancy tests
that you buy at you know the
store supermarket or pharmacy they're
you know they're pushing like 99
percentile accuracy so they're usually
pretty good
wait a second results in three minutes
how long should you weigh each brand and
everything like that
will vary some of them are a minute some
of them you know three minutes
just really depends but make sure you
read the packaging correctly so that
something like this
doesn't happen you know i think they did
a great job nine out of ten
everything was pretty accurate i think
it's fun and
obviously hysterical that he finds the
box and is like oh my goodness three
minutes
[Music]
wow that's one baby out actually this is
something that is very
possible i've had deliveries especially
when it's someone who's a multi-gravida
which means she's had
multiple pregnancies the more
pregnancies you have
typically the faster the labor course is
and so i've had women who you know it's
her fifth sixth baby and they come in
and you know once the baby is there and
crowning they just cough
and baby comes out if this were her
first pregnancy
probably not your body's never done it
before so it'd be very difficult
push here we go sometimes i find myself
like pushing almost for them because you
just
you know you want to try and help what
ends up happening a lot of the times
though that i've seen
when the partners are like this it
bothers the patient sometimes
and so they'll kind of be like go away
or you know don't stand next to me
you you know pull out this bar and it
connects to the bottom
like around the table and so the purpose
of that
is instead of you know you kind of
laying on your back with your legs up
and stir ups
this one kind of simulates a position of
squatting
when you prepare for a c-section no no
no no no i
i have a birth plan yeah we i want to
push i want to push
she had this birth plan but you know it
seems like an emergency is going on the
baby's heart rate was dropping
so at that point it would be an
indication for a c-section
there is kind of the saying on labor and
delivery
that if you have this you know rigid and
set birth plan
that it's going to end up in a c-section
we're not saying it as like a mean thing
but i think it's important that when you
are pregnant and going in to have a baby
you have to go with a mindset of
yes this is the birth plan that you want
but you have to be able to be
flexible to change because a lot of it
is out of our control
you know in this scene where the baby's
heart rate's dropping obviously no one
wants to see that
they did a pretty good job with you know
showing the different
scenarios that can take place nine out
of ten they did good
i can't do this yes you can
when you know she's obviously looking up
and saying i can't do this and kind of
panicking
that is extremely accurate
it's almost like they go into this like
panic mode
i always like to tell them that yes it
is extremely painful
this is temporary and they're gonna feel
so much better once they deliver
the whole breathing technique that she's
doing with the
i've never actually heard that in my
career it's just good to take
good big deep breaths you know in the
nose out through the mouth kind of stay
a little bit more calm
laying flat on their back on the floor i
don't think this is realistic
i don't find this position to be
comfortable most women
either whether they're doing home burst
or in the hospital
a lot of the times they're still either
squatting
they can kind of be on their back but
not flat almost just kind of
propped up almost like you're doing like
ab workout and you're kind of doing that
crunch position
i would say that's more comfortable than
just being flat on your back
it's going to be very hard to breathe
and be very uncomfortable because that's
a lot of weight
that's just kind of sitting on your
chest
babies actually do cry um as soon as
they're born and we want them to cry
and when they're in utero their lungs
aren't
working essentially so once they are
born
they're kind of squeezed on their way
out of the birth canal and they
give that first cry it actually helps
them kind of expand everything and make
sure everything's functioning
and sometimes they can swallow a little
bit of the amniotic fluid so by them
kind of crying and coughing it out it's
actually really helpful
that baby is spotless that baby is
very very clean immediately again
not something that is realistic at all
so i'd have to say they're one or two
out of ten
[Music]
cravings in pregnancy very very common
especially in the first trimester it can
start that early
and then the cravings can kind of change
as the pregnancy progresses
and i have heard some very interesting
combinations of food
a lot of pickle juice or pickles with
like chocolate
i've heard which does not sound good to
me
at all go ahead and treat yourself but
every now and then yeah it's not going
to hurt anything
if you're craving a deli sandwich or
anything like that
it's important that you make sure that
the meat is
hot the big thing is avoiding any sort
of raw meat
or raw fish obviously this is over
indulging but i think it's cute
it's funny so i'm going to say 8 out of
it's a 10. 140 beats a minute
perfectly normal when we're looking at
fetal heart rate
what's normal is anything between 110
beats per minute and 160 beats per
minute
so a fetus's heartbeat is definitely
much faster
and that is completely normal and
healthy even in the first trimester that
heartbeat can start pushing 180 and 190
beats per minute
and that's okay the sonogram ultrasound
does look realistic probably not his
hand movements on
the actual belly but the actual picture
does look good that little string of
pearls
he said oh look the string of pearls
that is not something we typically use
to describe the spine
oddly enough we do kind of describe it
as a railroad track
because you can kind of see two you know
it looks just like a railroad track
you got to move back in with me i want
you off your feet as much as possible
and no going to the lab
this is actually a recommendation that
is outdated
but before doing bed rest and having
someone stay off of their feet
was kind of recommended all the time
then a lot of these patients started
developing blood clots in their legs
or in their lungs and so they did a lot
of research on it and
actually having someone who's pregnant
on bed rest
is you know increased risk of blood
clots
the whole premise and plot of this movie
of having arnold
schwarzenegger you know trying out this
fertility drug and then consequently
ending up
pregnant um would be extremely
unrealistic
the ultrasound i thought was very
realistic
um but as something that is it gonna be
possible now
probably not so i would say
probably a three or four out of ten
that's not enough but
what are you doing i'm getting that baby
out of you
there's no real good data as to
you know any of these things that maybe
they're old wives tales or you know
things that you hear
that are gonna provoke labor is it gonna
hurt anything to try
no not really if you feel comfortable
and you find a comfortable position for
you
and you want to try and have sex to see
why not
the cervix in pregnancy which is the
bottom part of the uterus tends to be
pretty
sensitive in pregnancy so anything
that's going to you know touch the
cervix or anything like that that can
start
cramping and
[Music]
i contractions my water just broke the
majority of women their
water doesn't break spontaneously like
we see in the movies
this one's not quite as dramatic most
women you know contractions start and
their water just doesn't break it'll
break once they're
in the hospital okay i got the pillow uh
got the bag you got the keys i got the
keys i don't think there's
any sense for you to panic and you know
rush and things like that but you
certainly have time to
carefully grab your bags and you know be
rational
with your decisions get to the hospital
safely i think they do a really good job
and let's say seven
six out of ten this is your folic acid
and this is your prenatal vitamin you're
serious about this
definitely this is the most ridiculous
size
prenatal vitamin i have ever seen if you
have them that are this big please buy
yourself another brand because
this is just too much they're typically
just you know a regular
you know vitamin pill size i they even
come
in a gummy formation now which has all
the same nutrients
it's actually encouraged and recommended
to start taking
a prenatal vitamin i mean really for all
women who are of reproductive age
even if you're not planning on becoming
pregnant that actually helps the
development of a fetus
i can't do it i got it it's going
it is really funny but seeing a prenatal
vitamin that's that
that big not a thing or it shouldn't be
a thing
um so i'd say four out of ten